- La STM doit trouver
77,7 millions de dollars
pour balancer son budget
de 1,7 milliards, pour 2023
et demande l'aide de Québec.
ÉRIC ALAN CALDWELL, président
du conseil d'administration, STM
- Soyons clair; avec plus
d'ajustements que ce qu'on
propose, on changenininiveau
de service.
- "80 % des lignes ne seront pas
touchées," affirme la STM.
Pour le 20 % qui reste, certains
services d'autobus seront revus
pour diminuer la fréquence
des véhicules qui circulent vide
ou en ajouter sur les trajets
plus achalandés.
La STM dit ne pas vouloir
heheher aux lignes d'autobus
dont les passages sont aux
30 minutes, ni aux services
dans les quartiers industriels.
Toutefois, le temps d'attente
sur les quais de métro changera
sur certaines lignes aux heures
de pointe. Les rames de métro
passeront à un intervalle
de 2 minutes 45 secondes,
au lieu de 2 minutes 15 secondes
sur la ligne verte.
Et les périodes de pointes,
où le service est plus rapide,
seront diminuées de quelques
minutes sur la ligne orange.
- Si le métro passe moins
souvent, l'autobus aussi,
ça me gêne beaucoup.
- C'est un peu dommage pour
les personnes qui doivent
reposer là-dessus pour
leurs déplacements.
- Les gens qui vont vouloir
voyager auront moins...
n'auront certainement
pas accès à plus d'heures
- La STM assure que l'offre sera
similaire à 2022, mais concède
qu'elle n'a plus de marge
de manoeuvre.
SARAH V. DOYctctctctctrice
générale, Trajectoire Québec
- Des réductions, légères,
mais quand même des réductions
de services. On a quand mêmeprpi
à sauver les meubles
pour l'instant.
- Car l'achalandage ne semble
pas près de revenir au niveau
pré-pandémie.
MARIE-CLAUDE LÉONARD
directrice générale, STM
- Il faut prévoir qu'on aura
un 15 % de perte d'achalandage
pour les 10, 15 prochaines
années.
- Au cabinet de la ministre
des Transports, on affirme que
la mobilité durable fait partie
des priorités rnrnrnrnrnement,
mais que les choix budgétaires
de la STM relève de
l'administration municipal